since I do work for a Canadian show I
have to ask you about Queen the legend
Shania Twain yeah yes yeah what was it
like working with Shania
it's crazy cool yes nice the coolest
living legend I mean it's not every day
you get to work with a living legend and
I was a huge Shania Twain fan just like
growing up I loved to up to Shania Twain
I it was very very cool for me yeah it's
awesome
okay so how familiar were you with this
story and why did you want to take on
these roles I was not familiar with the
story I was not familiar with Jeremy's
music so I completely looked at this
whole thing with fresh eyes and I loved
it I thought it was kind of terrifying
to play the role but you know I think
everything kind of worked out yeah I
fell into place
beautifully I mean obviously there's a
lot of responsibility when you take on
real people and also such a you know a
story like this I mean can you sort of
talk a little bit about that process
that you went through yeah I mean I it's
definitely a huge responsibility playing
real people and and this story is not
something that just sort of came out of
thin air it was something that was very
intentional and I think the filmmaker
filmmakers were really careful about how
they respected Jeremy's story and Jeremy
had a huge part of the full process so
it was really just allowing them to kind
of guide us along the way and make sure
that we we told it as best as possible
yeah and to I mean to realize that we're
all here to to honor Melissa mm-hmm this
is her story and we're all headed to
tell it awesome so you guys are working
together again obviously what has that
been like second time around no it's
great
now we love it no it's good you know
what's so great about it is there's you
don't really have to put any extra
energy into it because you're already
exerting so much with this project I
mean on screen and then to to try and
keep someone happy on the sidelines the
whole time would have been like yes it's
like yeah we can whenever we needed
space to do anything it's like we didn't
even have to tell each other she's like
I don't have to wait just leave yeah
there was no light we didn't have to
take anything personally we both kind of
just had our own process and we were
able to respect that and that's like the
greatest gift yeah that's awesome
what is something that you would sell
[Laughter]
what's something that you want people to
take away or sort of learn whenever they
walk out of this film I hope people feel
inspired and uplifted and happy at the
end of it you know that's the goal is to
the goal for this movie for us I think
you know apart from you know that's big
the story being you know I'm told is I
think to inspire people with love you
know the world needs it the world needs
it right now we always need it and I
feel like I want people to want to be in
love you know get excited but yeah yeah
yeah yeah I agree with that well on that
note I think that's it for me